Will Smith's Oscar slap is still what
everybody's talking about now The Man
Behind what was already an historic
Oscar show will Packer is breaking his
silence over what exactly went down
behind the scenes
love will make you do crazy things
sounds like Chris Rock had the ability
the option to have the LAPD
go arrest and remove Will Smith from
that theater that night that's an
absolute fact the LAPD made it clear we
will do
whatever you want us to do and one of
the options is that we will go and
arrest him right now they were saying
this is battery we will go get him we
are prepared we're prepared to get him
right now you can press charges we can
arrest him and they said you know would
you like us to take any action and he
said no the Oscars producer told ABC
News at first he thought will slap was
staged that I said did he really hit you
and he looked at me and he goes yeah he
goes I just took a punch from Muhammad
Ali after the incident what happened to
the energy in the room it sucked
completely out of it
Packer claims at one point it looked
like Academy leaders were going to
forcibly remove Will Smith after he
refused to leave I said Chris Rock
doesn't want that I said Rock has made
it clear that he does not want to make a
bad situation worse that was Chris's
energy this tone was not retaliatory but
a source who was by the production
office while police were speaking with
Chris took issue with that part of
Packer's account our source says quote
Chris was never asked if he wanted to
have Will Smith removed from the theater
because Chris handled the moment with
such Grace and a prom it allowed the
show to continue
Will Smith has just 17 days till the
academy board meets to decide his fate
so can the actor come back from all of
this I say the apology tour needs to
start now we asked two experts crisis PR
specialist Mark Silverstein and Wall
Street journalist entertainment reporter
Joe Flynn I think America in general and
Hollywood in particular is often about
Second Chances and Redemption and if
you're sincere about them you can move
on from this he needs to start fixing
his brand we all know his brand good guy
great actor let's get back to that let's
get involved in the narrative
listen there is still so much more to
unpack from this situation absolutely
it's going to keep going and going and
evolving yeah it is
[Music]